welcome back to rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and spider-man into the
spider-verse recently revealed some
insane outlines filmmakers used to
rework the movies final act which gives
us an excuse to rewatch this amazing
film during this quarantine period I'm
not complaining on these barely readable
boards these secrets of what a person's
choices mean into the spider verses
finale so powerful and ultimate ending
moments that were removed or revised as
someone who has made boards like this
outline screenplays I have written and
none of them nearly as good as verse I
feel like I can translate this
frustrated writer ease so that we can
better appreciate the crap that bill
Lord Rodney Rothman and their talented
team put into this to give into the
spider verse and be perfect ending that
it has I'm gonna break down all these
social media posts with another new rock
stars that we found or in teen edition
okay so the movies filmmaker Phil Lord
tweeted that they did a big shake-up of
into the spider-verse story
less than a year from the release these
changes were made after the first teaser
for the movie came out with another
round as late as July 2018 after the
main trailer came out meaning these
folks worked late into the production
process tinkering with this final act
until they couldn't even tell what was
good anymore Lord said that these dry
erase boards represent a triage
situation of what moments of the finale
to keep what moments to cut and what
moments to rework and what order all
these things should come in so the red
riding represents the changes to the
final act jay or jeff refers to
jefferson miles father doc refers to doc
ock Olivia tibi escapee refers to
kingpin and the numbers are sequence
numbers that's how animated films
outline their stories to keep everything
organized so this board is referring to
the third act when the spider team
attempts to stop kingpins Collider from
spiraling in the spider versa to chaos
and send themselves back to their home
dimensions the plot elements here are
all chaotic and unordered listed in
order of adjustments the filmmakers
needed to make not necessarily
chronology but here we go
in blue you can see it's going to be
great for KP his family is arriving but
wait reveal spiders Peter says sorry
kingpin the party's over
this makes Vanessa go away doc attacks
Peter then in red changes Miles arrives
to save the day must prove himself to
Peter in order to save him miles saves
Gwen from weird
removes masks it smiles heart our team
gains upper-hand beatstock everyone gets
a moment miles triple lindy go by Gwen
line miles to Peter go now Peter says
you're not ready yet I don't want to
leave you there's things I can teach you
miles proves he's ready go Peter says
you're my one person mile says no I'm
not call your wife at miles faces KP
alone shoulder touch zap yay Soho let's
boil this all down to the major changes
to understand how this movie's finale
end up being so awesome change wanna the
key dramatic relationship of the film is
not miles and when it's miles and Peter
it seems like one of the biggest triage
points was which relationship in this
film is the greater priority in the
notes you could see a pitch for a
romantic rescue and unmasking reveal by
miles to Gwen it was gonna go down in
this cute way where he saves her from
something quirky but in the final cut
Myles does save Gwen but it really
happens much faster it ends up being
part of a big group flip for goodbye to
Myles was also way more platonic than
romantic and in a way that into being
far more cathartic for the two friends
cool really you can see on the boards
the light bulb moment that miles
relationship with Peter B Parker is far
more important to his journey the two
get a separate debate in which they save
each other and decide to let each other
go
so that Peter can go make things work
with MJ and his home dimension and that
decision by miles is executed with a
solid call back returning Peter's move
against him in act 1 sweep in the leg
and grabbing the shirt and that brings
us to the second big change callbacks
and character moments if you think about
the most satisfying part of this finale
is the way it's a team effort with each
character getting a moment and playing
an essential role each move being a kind
of callback associate editor Andy Levitt
on shared a later reworking to the final
act that he used to piece together the
sequence with changes like noir using
his hat instead of a gun to defeat
tombstone and all choke pitches for noir
like telling spider-ham either some pig
or that'll do Pig playing on whether you
want to to reference Charlotte's Web or
babe the final act is all callback so
the lessons Myles learned from his
mentor figures mouths and Peter
effectively whip together Peter uses the
same kind of sequence of movement that
he saw the first Peter Parker use and
act 1 and of course the move from uncle
Aaron shoulder Pat a and Zach yeah this
vigil was definitely outlined on that
board the change that is hardest to
decipher is the way they've reordered a
lot of these moments like it's one thing
to map out everything you would want to
happen in the finale but the really
impressive part of the writing process
comes in the order in sequencing to
produce the greatest emotional effect a
general principle in screenwriting is
that your characters opposing forces
should be defeated in ascending order of
their threat level and ideally reverse
order that they were introduced notice
on the outline boards that kingpins plan
to bring back his wife and son seems to
be working for him and then he turmoils
it and that's what starts the whole
battle but in the final cut kingpins
participation in the battle comes at the
very end
instead of making Vanessa within arm's
reach at the top of the battle they
bring her in later as a distraction one
last thing to drive kingpin to a
breaking point in his fight with miles
so now the defeat order goes tombstone
scorpion Hawk and then kingpin in the
reverse order of their threat level and
the threat that campaign levies is an
explicit one toward miles family family
that is now within miles
I'll on
my family now I'm gonna make sure you
never see yours again and that leads to
the one final opposing force this movie
saves for the very end of the film miles
father so the editors updated reworking
also includes this interesting though
model saves Jay Jay looks up miles Khan
like Batman let me try and explain that
this refers we've removed Indian scene
where miles saves his dad which you can
actually see in the alternate universe
mode on the Blu ray gone like Batman
refers to miles comically whooshing
upward out of frame I got a jokey thing
but instead of this earlier alternate
version of the scene the Final Cut
version of miles reunion with Jefferson
is simple and heartfelt a concerned
phone call a hug and I love you circling
back to in resolving miles final dilemma
introduced in the opening sequence so
when new rock star spends all of our
time analyzing these movie spring by
frame it's because the filmmakers spent
all of their time revising and revising
to give these movies layers of meaning
for us to discover which version of
miles see with his dad do you prefer
comment down below and a reminder that
you can join our unfiltered conversation
about all this stuff on discord by
becoming a patron of new rock stars at
patreon.com slash new rock stars follow
me a TA of us follow new rock stars and
subscribe to new rock stars to
breakdowns and everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]